okay there's a real problem going on for
progressive youtubers I've already told
many of you that there's this thing
called YouTube ad pocalypse as a result
of some articles that were written in
corporate media alleging that the
YouTube ad algorithm is too relaxed on
March 31st YouTube turned on a new ad
algorithm which destroyed the david
pakman show YouTube channel and we
actually have a sort of revenue graph to
put up on the screen for people who may
not be aware of what went on and what
you will see on this graph is that we
went from point one on the graph where
things were going along pretty well to
point two which represented a loss of 99
percent of our revenue and I was told at
the time by YouTube of staff that the
situation would resolve itself that we
could expect an improvement and we did
see that improvement as we approached
point 3 on the graph we recovered about
30 to 35 percent of our revenue and I
was hoping that things were on the
up-and-up
but then on July 1st as you can see by
0.4 on this picture on this graph we
lost about 85 to 88 percent of our
revenue this has happened for two
reasons number one the number of ads
playing is down to about 30% meaning
that for every 10 video views only three
ads are playing compare this with about
70 percent prior to ad pocalypse
the second issue is that the ad quality
has gone down and what I mean by that is
the there are there are different tiers
of ads on YouTube there are what are
called reserve ads which are the good
ones and then there are action ads which
are the not so well paying ones we used
to have about a 50/50 split between high
and low quality ads we now have 1% high
quality ads so this is a combination of
factors and it's a disaster now when
this happened to us I wondered I said to
myself is this just happening to us is
this happening to other progressive
youtubers so I started reaching out to
many of the people that I'm in touch
with who but you would absolutely know
but they might not want to be you know
publicly mentioned so I won't mention
them but all the names you're probably
familiar with and I started saying hey
are you experiencing this as of July 1st
everybody all of these progressive
youtubers are experiencing the exact
same thing now do I believe someone is
deliberately hurting progressive
youtubers by messing with the YouTube
algorithm no I'm not saying that
possible but I have no evidence of that
what I am Telling You is that the effect
of this is that it's endangering
progressive media progressive media is
particularly in danger as a result of
this and as I told you yesterday there's
a three pronged destructive attack of
circumstances on progressive youtubers
right now number one the Trump
administration wants more legal options
against media outlets this includes
libel lawsuits this includes going
legally criminally after media
publishers of information that a leaker
provided to them which would be a
significant change in US policy on that
issue number two we've got the attempt
to rollback Obama era net neutrality
regulations which would also be a
disaster for independent producers like
us and number three you've got the
YouTube advertiser boycott which
continues to be a redistribution of
advertising dollars away from
independent producers like us to
corporate media it's that I mean there's
there's no other way that I can explain
to you that this is absolutely crushing
and whether it's us or some other show
the important thing is if you want to
see these programs survive you should
seriously consider making some financial
contribution as small as it may be it
doesn't have to be our show there's some
other show you like better and if you
look at the youtube comments on our
channel I don't think you'll be
surprised to hear that there are many
people who like other shows better than
this one whatever show you like consider
making a contribution because this is a
major major big deal membership is an
option as I've told you before you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership you pick a
monthly or yearly membership you click
on that red signup button and then you
will see a coupon code filled you can
get a 40% discount off of membership by
using the coupon code
I voted 17 if you don't want to deal
with any of the membership stuff and you
don't have time to watch more content
and you can go to patreon.com/scishow
this is quick and easy you're just
throwing us a dollar a month or two
dollars a month or whatever amount works
for you and that will help to offset the
impact of this three-pronged attack on
independent media that is
disproportionately affecting progressive
programs like ours it's bad out there
Pat and I just want to be totally
upfront with everybody about what's
going on
sure in different channels different
shows are taking a different response to
this and you know for some that may mean
taking their full show off of YouTube
something that we don't want to do
absolutely others it just means
incorporating the YouTube advertiser
boycott in their day to day content or
and for some others it may be you know
sponsored material on their channels
right and we just think that mentioning
it in this format is the best way for us
because it just fits what we do if my
approach is if we can get enough people
to replace the lost revenue with a
dollar here and there we don't have to
change anything and that would really be
the ideal situation for us